[Musique]
l'ambiance est à la fête à la maison de
l'afrique dans la petite italie
au menu quelques plats typiques de
l'afrique de l'ouest c'est de produits
cultivés ici même à montréal
à l'origine africaine si nos boss
harrachi ici en arabie simple fameux
biscuit ce qu'on écrive originaires du
niger hamidou rêve de faire découvrir
les saveurs de l'afrique
quand je suis arrivé ici je me suis pas
comptable et puis ben rapidement je
commence à chercher des légumes frais
qui étaient des légumes qui ressemble à
ce que moi je cultivais d'abord en
afrique mais aussi des légumes eric et
moi je fais la cuisine pour mes enfants
et les plats qu'on avait l'habitude de
manger là bas j'en ai trouvé uniquement
séchées ou bien en concert à vous bien
congelés et puis ben rapidement je me
suis demandé est-ce qu'il ya moyen de
les faire pousser ici hamidou abandonne
la comptabilité pour se consacrer à
l'agriculture urbaine
il s'inscrit à l'institut de technologie
agroalimentaire de saint-hyacinthe avec
un projet bien précis en tête
les guerres ethniques la formation inter
et tubesque ça m'a suivi pendant toute
ma formation tout le monde habib ou se
lancent à la recherche de viseo
tropicaux qui ont le potentiel d'être
cultivés au québec
je plantais maigrin depuis je sais de
l'observation je notais températures
auxquelles elle était je me tais si
j'avais à oser pas aux découverts parle
pas couverts et puis donc déjà de la
première année se commencer vraiment
avoir une belle collection à l'été 2010
est il lance son entreprise
hamidou horticulture qui propose une
sélection de 70 plants tropicaux dont
l'ocrha morel de quito la pomme
kangourou et même les arachides est en
créatures ou au québec un été ne sont
pas inséré la température en afrique
c'est la longueur le secteur de lac est
différente
donc il faut adapter sa avec une période
de production en serre
la maison de l'afrique accueille depuis
cet été un jardin urbain ou hamidou
atlantis et légumes exotiques alors
faire un tour pour vous montrer un peu
légumes qu'on a ici un passionnant où
c'est devenu une entreprise bel objet
qui se décide à porter aux gens des
souvenirs soir sont des immigrants soit
référence aux diffuseurs génération
affidés souvenir de la houle d'ouest
qu'ils viennent soit ce sont des
personnes qui ont voyagé qui sont allés
dans différents pays du monde qui ont
goûté un plat typique d'une région
extension avenue veulent parce qu'ils
sont de la cuisine essaie de reproduire
ce plat aujourd'hui à la maison de
l'afrique c'est fatima qui a préparé
différents plats africains comme la
sauce gombo
c'est à partir d'os kraft au cra on peut
dire qu'on le mange à toutes les sauces
dans l'afrique le cas c'est quelque
chose que qui est tellement important
pour moi de trouver je devrais quand je
suis arrivé on n'avait quasiment pas
maintenant on commence à avoir de plus
en plus comme en temps de trouver dans
les épiceries mme mais le plat qui lui
rappellent davantage ses racines
c'est la source aux arachides mieux
connue au sénégal sous le nom de masse
et le mas est un plat simple composé
d'oignons de tomates de piment et bien
sûr de pâte d'arachide
la même moi je fais le mafieux mais pas
simple de professionnels l'arachide
l'ingrédient essentiel de cette sauce
pousse dans un sol bien drainé sec comme
ici au cameroun au québec l'été pluvieux
va donner du fil à retordre à midi si
cette personne en suit les conseils que
je leur ai donné plaisant mis dans le
temps des conditions d'un dépôt bien
dans des endroits a sonné en laissant
s'assécher sûr que eux ils ont eu des
exemples déjà commencé à récolter les
avis aux amateurs de légumes exotiques
hamidou à un autre conseil pour profiter
de ces plans la majorité qu'on a faim de
fruits te faire déjà ses fruits entre
conserver ces graines chez soi à la
maison puis l'année d'après ben les
replanter pour soi même pour ça que ce
moment j'ai dit à mes clients si vous
avez de la chance et si vous le faites
bien vous achetez ce temps là une seule
fois avec moi d'après vos propres
semences